you know
writers like stephen king you know often
talk about like their process
of you know what they do like what they
eat when they wake up
like uh when they sit down like how they
like their desk
have you know on a on a perfectly
productive day
like what they like to do how long they
like to work for
what enables them to think deeply all
that kind of stuff
hunter s thompson did a lot of drugs uh
everybody has their own thing
uh what's do you have a thing is there
if you were to lay out a perfect
productive day
what would that schedule look like do
you think
part of that's hard to answer because i
like um the mode of work i do changes a
lot
from day to day like some days i'm
writing the thing i have to do is write
a script some days i'm animating the
thing i have to do is animate
sometimes i'm like working on the
animation library the thing i have to do
is like
a little i'm not a software engineer but
something in the direction of software
engineering
some days it's like a variant of
research it's like learn this topic
well and try to learn it differently so
those is like four
very different modes of what it some
days is like get through the email
backlog of people i've been
the tasks i've been putting off um it
goes research scripting
like the idea starts with research and
then they're scripting
and then there's programming and then
there's the uh
showtime and the research side by the
way i like what's
i think a problematic way to do it is to
say i'm starting this project
and therefore i'm starting the research
instead it should be that you're like
ambiently learning a ton of things
just in the background and then once you
feel like you have the understanding for
one you put it on the list of things
that
there can be a video for otherwise um
either you're going to end up
roadblocked forever or you're just not
going to
like have a good way of talking about it
but still some of the days it's like the
thing to do is learn new things
so what's the most painful one i think
you mentioned scripting
scripting is yeah that's the worst yeah
right writing is the worst so what's
your
on a perfectly so let's take the hardest
one what's a perfectly productive day
you wake up and it's like damn it this
is the day i need to do some scripting
and like you didn't do anything last two
days so you came up with excuses to
procrastinate so today must be the day
yeah i uh i wake up early i i guess i
exercise um
and then uh i turn the internet off uh
if if we're writing yeah that's that's
what's required um is having the
internet off
and then maybe you keep notes on the
things that you want to google when
you're allowed to have the internet
again
i'm not great about doing that but when
i do that makes it happen and then when
i hit writer's block
like the solution to writer's block is
to read it doesn't even have to be
related
just read something different just for
like 15 minutes half an hour and then go
back to writing
um that when it's a nice cycle i think
can work very well
and when you when you're writing the
script you don't know where it ends
right like you have like problem-solving
videos i know where it ends
expositional videos i don't know where
it ends like coming up with uh
with the magical thing that makes this
whole story like ties this whole story
together
is that when does that happen that's
that's the thing that makes it such that
a topic gets put on the list of like
oh that's an issue you shouldn't start
the project unless there's one of those
uh and you have you have so many nice
bags that you haven't such a big bag of
aha moments already that you could just
pull at it
that's one of the things and one of the
sad things about time and that nothing
lasts forever
and that we're all mortal let's not get
into that um
discussion uh is you know
if i see like even when i ask for people
to ask like ask
i did a call for questions and people
want to ask you questions i mean so many
requests from people about like certain
videos that would love you to do
it's such a pile and
i i think that's a that's a sign of like
admiration
from people for sure but it's like it
makes me sad because like whenever i see
them
people give ideas they're all like very
often really good ideas
and it's like it's such a
makes me sad in the same kind of way
when i go through a library
or through a bookstore you see all these
amazing books that you'll never get to
open
so so yeah so so you yeah you gotta
enjoy the ones that you have
enjoy the books that are open and don't
let yourself
lament the ones that stay closed what
else is there any other magic to that
day
do you try to dedicate like a certain
number of hours
do uh cal newport has this deep work
kind of idea
i'm there's systematic people who like
get really
on top of you know they checklist of
what they're going to do in the day and
they like count their hours and i am not
a systematic person
in that way it's which is probably a
problem i
very likely would get more done if i was
systematic in that way but that doesn't
happen
um so you know maybe talk to me talk to
me later in life and maybe i'll
have like changed my ways and give you a
very different answer
i think benjamin franklin like later in
life figured out the rigor
he has these like very rigorous
schedules and what how how to be
productive
i think those schedules are much more
fun to write like it's very fun to like
write a schedule and make a blog post
about like the perfect productive day
um that like might work for one person
but i don't know how much people get out
of like reading them or trying to
adopt someone else's style and i'm not
even sure that they've ever followed
yeah exactly like you're always gonna
write it as the best version of yourself
um you're not going to explain the
phenomenon of like wanting to get out of
the bed but not really wanting to get
out of bed
and all of that
you